hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
brian stelter is still an unlikable
potato
dallas column in this morning's new york
times basically says that joe biden
should not run for reelection this has
been a narrative for months and it's
getting louder and louder including from
some democratic lawmakers saying
biden should uh basically hang it up and
and and say he's a lame duck and and not
run 2024. so where do you come down on
this as a former white house aide oh i
hope he runs and i know he's going to
run i think he's planning to run um as
he said many times um but look i think
that it is this is arriving right on
time it's like it's democratic
bedwetting time um in 1995 right around
this time uh rw apple wrote a piece in
the new york times wait are you saying
the media is predictable very
predictable
this is very different this time
barack obama bill clinton barack obama
they all
makes it different well to you guys but
after you look at the week he just had
and those wins that he racked up
while he had covered i don't see i don't
see why he wouldn't run i haven't got
the reason why what about hunter hunter
under federal investigation charges
could be coming at any time this is not
just a right-wing media story this is a
real problem for the bidens could he
decide not to run for reelection given
his son look they make they make
decisions as a family and um they will
make that decision uh when it's time but
do you think they've talked about it yet
no they're the president's doing his job
he's doing his work he's not focused on
that it's 19 months
why would he be doing that um okay so
you're saying the press is getting ahead
of way ahead way ahead look there's more
work to do
uh it's been 19 months and um
you know
he's he intends to run like you said but
i think we i think
i think the focus should be from the
press on how what he is doing is
affecting people out in the country
because these are things that democrats
have wanted to get done for a long time
and just over in just a week veterans
manufacturing
the unemployment rate
it's it's been remarkable to see a
president rack up so many substantive
wins as even your anchors have noted in
the last year